[Musique]
chanter quelque chose ça sera plus
naturel chanter
c'est comme ça qu'on fait des films
ça vous plaît pas on arrête le tournage
plan B oui plan B on va finir le montage
chez la tente de marque
désolé de vous embêter à donner au point
mort je voulais être patiente et l'aider
à retrouver son chemin et fait un
documentaire sur une fourmi
ça fait deux jours qui fait que ça il
faut démarrer son projet comme on
démarre une voiture en hiver le livre
des solutions c'est quoi le livre des
solutions le livre des solutions devait
être un recueil de réponse à tous les
conflits mon chef-d'œuvre
qui s'était arrêté au titre
démarre ton projet fais ce que tu veux
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ton camion Tage tu
tournes le volant à droite et pour
couper tu klaxonnes
apprends en faisant derrière vraiment
bien ton film et à l'arrière on installe
des producteurs ils peuvent rien voir
les producteurs
vous allez interpréter mon corps c'est
tout simple
ça va aller tu t'en sors bien
[Applaudissements]
il y a des victoires tellement
éclatantes qu'elles n'ont pas besoin de
voir
[Musique]